you know i once made
dinner for my mom and she said oh my
gosh darling this is so delicious and i
said mom you got to try it first before
you give me the compliment i opened the
door for an elderly lady you would have
thought that i won the nobel peace prize
do you allow yourself to have
expectations no yeah i don't either i
think expectations are the catalyst to
so much unhappiness and are grounded in
wild selfishness and lack of energy let
me start with this
i
love your books because it's popular
culture documentaries
in written form is that fair i think
it's it's good news for me because the
approach that i
you know look oral histories
i think are
really important because there's no way
even ernest hemingway at a keyboard can
convey the varisimilitude the
sensibilities the uniqueness of
everyone's individual voice and
perspectives and so when you have like
in the snl book when you have billy
murray talking about the last time you
saw gilda radner live or
in this book when you
when i was talking to david chase and
julia louis dreyfus and i mean literally
hundreds of others i did 757 interviews
because
i feel like it's a great opportunity for
readers to
get behind the curtain and really hear
directly from the people involved but
i'm trying to create a book of record
whereby
i can come in and i can use supplemental
facts like sometimes financial
information or other things just ratings
or sales i remember you know it's funny
you just said that that subscriptions to
kate you know like i've always loved
that you've done that because what
you're doing is you're helping me the
reader because a lot of times
what you have in your books is you have
two different people describing the same
event from you know
very different points of view just as
humans like to do things and i think
effectively in the ones that i've i read
you bring in an outside voice that kind
of brings some non-debatable data that
not that it steers you to believe one
person the other it's just there as an
anchoring for why while i interpret you
like origin stories me too mister here
we go your origin stories what what put
you in the position to have one of the
more significant careers in writing i
mean most immediately i i got divorced
when i had a nine seven and three year
old and uh i was an executive before
that and uh i decided that i wanted to
uh raise my kids and so i had shared
joint custody whole time and that's when
i became a full-time writer and uh that
gave me the opportunity to
uh be at home and take the kids to
school pick the kids school up live with
i mean they're with me half the time and
i i wrote in my my entire professional
schedule was built around my kid's life
and i think you know i wouldn't do it
any differently um i always enjoyed
writing i worked at the washington post
both for the new york times and other
things but um look i think writing as
you well know that it's a solitary
enterprise for the most part i mean
unless you're working on a tv show and
you're in a writer's room or whatever
and uh i think i enjoy interaction with
others and i i like the idea of working
with a team and being part of a team but
um for me it was uh it was no contest
and the the choice was uh turned out to
be a great one because i got to be you
know with my kids you've taken me to
your adult life i really want to know
about the neighborhood and the parenting
and the foundational things i think i
had uh polar opposites for parents you
know i once made
dinner for my mom and she said oh my
gosh darling this is so delicious and i
said mom you gotta try it first before
you give me the compliment and uh it was
that i mean there was kind of like
unbridled
enthusiasm and devotion blind yeah and
uh my dad was just the opposite he was
very consumed by classical music so we
listened to a lot of i wasn't allowed to
listen to rock and roll except on
headphones and he would uh you know his
way of coping was uh
classical music and poker and uh
so uh he lived that life because they
were on opposite ends you know end zones
there was nothing between the 40 yard
lines that i kind of learned while i was
living at home i think that was a lesson
that i had to learn you know once i went
off to school and then in jobs you know
i mean look i remember the first time i
did something at a job
and uh my editors i was at the
washington post my editor said
yeah this is good and then walked away i
was like where's like the big golden
star that my mom used to you know give i
remember exactly where i was in
plainfield jersey in the bradley
shopping center at mcdonald's i opened
the door for an elderly lady you would
have thought that i won the nobel peace
prize my mom lost her [ __ ] you are a
gentleman you are a [ __ ]
you are a golden-hearted boy the way you
treat people not just your sister but
this woman i think about myself i'm a 46
year old man and there was two areas of
positive reinforcement for me in the
first 15 18 years of my life two core
positive reinforcement engines in my
life was my mother on the category of
behavior what i would call emotional
intelligence kindness as a framework and
the business world and i'm a 46 year old
man who is black and white
a
very good businessman who is obsessed
with teaching people that you can be
nice and a good businessman and i sit
there and i'm like my god and this is
like how many people get affected like
the things that i look at people who
struggle because school is their
positive reinforcement engine and then
real life comes in and there's nothing
similar to it as a matter of fact one of
my biggest fears about modern parenting
is that parents are obsessed
when they have the luxury to be
paying attention which many parents in
america definitely do um
with eliminating any adversity in their
child's life we used to go outside like
our parents didn't know [ __ ] oh my god
no idea if you're over 45 a lot of us
remember living life where
not only our parents didn't know they
didn't even know where we were we went
out and they couldn't track us down
because there were no phones the high
percentage of us kept that [ __ ] to
ourselves and worked it through yes
except that sometimes we don't even
realize that we displace you know we we
kind of like hold on to some of those
things and then we displace them in our
adult lives without even being you know
kind of aware of it i get do you allow
yourself to have expectations
no yeah i don't either i think
expectations are are the catalyst to so
much unhappiness and are grounded in
wild selfishness and lack of empathy
yeah i mean it's just like setting it's
not being negative it's about
it's about managing your life in a way
that you know waking up every day you
know are you going to allow others to
disappoint you and are you good is your
antenna going to be so high that you're
going to get affected by
the way they say something or if they
don't say something and then that's
going to set you off on a you know dark
path so when you don't have expectations
for the negative you also don't have it
for the positive which allows you to be
grounded in humility
which is very powerful what's the thing
that everybody who's listening can take
from
the
hbo story if they're an individual or an
executive of like what was the
driving soul
that helped it become what it became a
word of warning to
entrepreneurs and innovators just
because you come up with the idea just
because you give birth to something
doesn't mean that you will be entitled
to stay with it bill rasmussen basically
invented espn
and chuck dolan basically invented hbo
neither of them were around after a year
and a half
the parent companies took them out
because they saw them
more as a
idm person rather than an operational
person and they didn't get to stay
around that's incredibly painful and so
be careful when the lord wants to punish
you he answers your prayers you can't
just innovate once and then
take a break it is innovation has to be
part of your dna why is it why is the
book called tinderbox because the idea
of hbo and hbo throughout the decades
has been flammable it it
it literally blew up the business it
changed television in some ways it
changed our culture it changed
storytelling it changed technology the
myriad impacts that hbo had beyond just
that little
desktop
that sat on your television and so i
kind of like the combustible quality of
that what what are some of the key
ingredients to a storyteller like
yourself who's grounded in listening for
people who are
good at what they do and who have a road
of accomplishment that they've traveled
on i you have to generally be um
absorbed by them do you think
curiosity is a core strength of yours
it's essential
i mean if i don't wake up in the morning
curious or if i embark upon
a book or any kind of reading assignment
or any any day
even if i'm not writing that day um if
i'm not curious about something that's
like oxygen for me i i just
you know i might as well just fold up
the tent and uh
you know
watch an old movie
[Music]